مراسم تشييع جنازه القيادي العسكري
الميداني في حزب الله وسام الطويل قامت
طائره مسيره حربيه اسرائيليه باطلاق صاروخ
على سياره على مقربه تبعد نحو اقل من
كيلومتر من المكان الذي يجري فيه التشييع
مراسم جنازه التشييع وعندما تم اطلاق هذا
الصاروخ افدت من قبل الموجودين هنا بوقوع
اصابات في تلك السياره التي جرى استهدافها
وهي على مقربه
من من منزل شقيق الشهيد وسام الطويل الذي
تم استهدافه من قبل الطائرات المسيره
الاسرائيليه وهذا الامر كان قد
تكرر اذا امكنك ان تبتعد اكثر عن مصدر
الصوت فقط حتى نستطيع ماذا عن
شقيق عن شقيق
القيا وسام طويل
لا ما كنت اقول ما كنت اقوله ليلى بان تم
استهداف سياره على مقربه من منزل شقيق
وسام طويل القيادي في حزب الله الذي جرى
استهدافه من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واستشهد في الغاره والاستهداف الذي ادى
الى
استشهاد تم اطلاق هذه الصواريخ باتجاه
السياره ولدينا معلومات اوليه عن ان هنالك
اصابات في هذه في هذا الاستهداف الذي يبعد
اقل من كيلومتر واحد عن مكان مراسم
الجنازه التشييع التي نشاهدها الان او
التي تحصل في وسط بلده خربه سلر حيث احتشد
كما تشاهدون بعدسه الكاميرا تشاهدون
المئات هنا سواء من سكان هذه القريه او من
قرى المحيطه بالاضافه الى
مسؤولين دينيين وحزبيين من حزب الله ومن
غيرها من الاحزاب اللبنانيه الذين تقاطروا
الى هنا الى بلده
العسكريه الميدانيه لحزب الله واستهدافه
يعتبر ضربه مؤلمه للحزب وهذا ما دفعه
بطبيعه الحال الى توجيه المسيرات الانقراض
وفق البيان الذي صدر صباح اليوم
ومهاجمه قاعده ددو الاسرائيليه في عمق صفر
والتي تبعد 12 كيلت عن الحدود وحز هو اعلن
في بيانه ان هذه العمليه التي نفذها في
العمق الاسرائيلي هي تاتي ردا على اغتيال
القيادي في حركه حماس صالح العاروري وايضا
ردا على اغتيال وسام الطويل الذي يعتبر من
ابرز القيادات العسكريه الميدانيه لحزب
الله والذي كان له باع طويل في في مجموعه
كبيره من المعارك التي خاضها في مواجهه
قوات الاحتلال وهو كان من ضمن المجموعه
التي نفذت وخططت لعمليه اسر الجنود الاسرا
اسرائيليين عام 2006 وهو ما ادى الى
اندلاع المواجهات في جنوب لبنان والعدوان
الاسرائيلي حينها عام 2006 ما يمكن رصده
ليلى من خلال كل هذه المراسم التي تقام
هنا بان حزب الله اراد من هذه المراسم ان
تكون بهذه الطريقه تحديدا لايصال مجموعه
من الرسائل لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بانه مستمر في النهج الذي يعمل عليه وفي
الاستهدافات المتكرره لقوات الاحتلال
وبالتالي من هنا يمكن ان نفهم بان هذه
العمليه التي جرت اليوم وتحديدا استهداف
القاعده العسكريه بدلالاتها المتعدده وهي
القاعده الرئيسيه التي تدير كافه عمليات
القوات البريه الاسرائيليه عند الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان نحن نتحدث عن قاعده تعتبر
قياده منطقه الشمال في القوات البريه
الاسرائيليه وهي تدير وتنظم عمل فرقتين
رئيسيتين الفرقه 911 التي تعنى بالقطاع
الشرقي من جنوب لبنان والفرقه 146 لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتي تعنى بالقطاع
الغربي وبالتالي توجيه الاستهداف نحو هذه
القاعده التي قال حزب الله بانها بان هذه
القاعده هي قاعده للتحكم والسيطره على كل
العمليات البريه التي تحصل على طول الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان وبالتالي هذا الاستهداف
ضمن عمق يبعد 12
كيلومترا يبعد 12 كيلومترا من من الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان يعني ضمنيا بان هنالك
محاوله ل لتوجيه رسائل واضحه عمليه اسر
الجنود الاسرائيليين عام
2006 الاستهداف هذا الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
من خلال اطلاق الصواريخ من احدى المسيرات
باتجاه بلده خربه سلم اثناء مراسم التشييع
لم يكن هو الاول ليله هذا الامر حصل سابقا
في ايضا في عيط الشعب حينها تم توجيه
الصواريخ باتجاه منقه
شهه الب انطلاقا من هنا يمكن ان نفهم بان
ثمه معادلات تكسر وخطوط حمراء باتت تقطع
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهذا ما
نشاهده ونراقب طيله الفتره الماضيه ليله
من خلال مجموعه كبيره من الاستهدافات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه اليوم نحن نتحدث
بالاضافه الى هذا الاستهداف في عمق بلده
خربه سلم ايضا في بلده خارج اطار المواجه
الامام نتحدث عن بلده الغندور هذه البلده
ضمن ضمن محافظه النبطيه وقضاء بنت جبيل تم
استهداف سياره هناك مما ادى الى استشهاد
ثلاثه اشخاص وبطبيعه الحال هذه
الاستهدافات باتت متكرره نحن نتحدث عن
مجموعه كبيره من الاستهدافات لم تعد ترتبط
فقط بالخط الامامي الحدودي للبنان ولم نعد
نتحدث عن الحافه الاماميه التي تعرف
بانها الابرز للمواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي